Once we have identified Independently Testable Features, the next step is to
identify the Relevant Inputs for each one of these features. And there are
many ways to do that. So, what we're going to do, instead of
looking at them all, is that we're just going to focus on two different
ways of doing it. And they are fairly general ways. So, they
are applicable to a number of situations. And in addition, what I will
do, I will point you to other sources in which you can
look at different ways of doing this in the class notes. The problem
of identifying relevant inputs for some Software or some feature
of it is called Test Data Selection and can be expressed
as followed. Let's consider our software as usual we have
our Input Domain, which is the set of inputs for all
the software. And again as usual, we have our Output
Domain, which is the set of corresponding outlets for these inputs.
So the question here is, how can we select a meaningful
set of inputs in my domain? And of course corresponding outputs
because we know that test cases are an input, plus an
expected output. So how can we select interesting inputs for our
software? So a set of inputs that, after we run them
on the software, if the software behaves correctly, we'll have enough
confidence that the software is correctly implemented. So one possible idea
is, hey, why don't we just test them all? We just
do exhaustive testing. We do all the inputs, nowadays we have
powerful machines, we have a lot of computational power in the cloud.
Why not just doing it? So to answer that
question, what I'm going to do? I'm going to use another quiz.